[Applaudissements]
voir les enfants au foie nous vous
apportons une surprise ce soir où une
surprise pour nicolas pas preneur oh que
je suis content nounours est aussi
content que si la surprise était pour
lui à l'on descend vite la porter à t2
petit ami ou le chef nicolas improbable
famille pop hip hop au soir les enfants
j'apporte la surprise que je vous ai dit
c'est pour moi non c'est pour moi aussi
bon que dans celle là au co
je vous ai bien c'est dans l'autre et
voici du dominion demoiselle tortue
dis donc c'est une grotte des
demoiselles tu adores des mais non c'est
une torture nicolas pense que c'est mal
et ravi 5 nov et là de tout petit pas
tout qu'est ce qu'il vient c'est mon ami
le grand marabout magie coco qui me l'a
offerte aux cages danic est ce qu'il est
gentil ces grands marabouts
merci grand ballet coco alors elle vous
plaît les enfants merci messi petit ardi
bien cherché à gémenos
c'est très possible et les très gros
boyaux tortue du afin que veux tu
mangeais et la confiture de fraises
veux-tu de la confiture de fraise non
qu'elle a souvent fait mal je soupe aux
poireaux lot no1 le barça est bien
petite tortue je vais te chercher de la
salade verte rien entendre et moi je
t'apporte de l'eau fraîche car tu as
sûrement soif
petite tortue se voit au de soin de bien
mon ami belge coco le grand marabout va
être très très coton
voilà deux lampes était tordue et de la
salle est déjà qu'elle est mignonne et
elle est pas fière annonce mais il se
ferme ma parole
notre demoiselle un sommeil allons
maintenant qu'elle a tout ce qu'il faut
à boire et à manger
nous allons lui dire bonne nuit
demoiselle actuellement gelée petite
heure tu fais de beaux rêves
[Musique]
sinon demain on jouera encore avec la
demoiselle avec la petite tortue
oui oui les enfants jettent à la lueur
de ne ni bolt ni petit tôt bonne nuit de
noces à matadi partenaires bonne nuit
mes chers petits amis demain nous
viendront voir cette jolie tortue
embrasser bien fort vos parents et aller
vite au dodo vu qu on ne voit pas trop
en route fidèle compagnon bonne nuit à
demain faute de bourret